ces six kusel c'est de la gesticulation
bien il ya en tout cas je pense qu'ils
sont pas très à l'air ça c'est très à
l'aise certains nerfs seriez cirque à
certains postes certaine mesure sur l'
isf et sur la taxation des revenus
financiers
la fameuse flat tax c'est des mesures
qu'ils auraient voulu faire ils n'ont
jamais fait donc voilà donc je suis rien
de danakil l'on cherche la vente d'un
car de là dessus sur lui et c'est fou
quand même pas très à l'aise
bon ça c'est un peu voilà après la
bascule entre la cgt cette pâte ouillage
effectivement ça assez complexe et pas
l'idée s'est allégé pour le coût du
travail bon c'est pas c'est pas malin
comme un décor qu'elle sait pas limpide
pour le commun des mortels c'est rapide
et bon ça on me l'accordé ça fait un
gain de pouvoir d'achat pour les actifs
vont très bien guillaume n'est pas
certain